Encuestamos a directores, policías, camioneros, cocineros, ingenieros.
Si la gente está empleada, entonces nosotros los hemos encuestado.
Y lo que sabemos en materia de su felicidad es:
Todos los trabajadores quieren lo mismo.
[La forma en que trabajamos]
Hay 3000 millones de trabajadores en el mundo.
Y alrededor del 40 % de ellos están felices en el trabajo.
Eso significa que 1800 millones o casi 2000 millones de personas
no son felices en el trabajo
¿Qué supone eso para esas personas
y para las organizaciones en las que trabajan?
Hablemos de dinero.
Las organizaciones que tienen muchos empleados felices
tienen tres veces más de crecimiento de sus ingresos,
En comparación con organizaciones donde eso no se da.
Estas superan el mercado de valores por un factor de tres.
Y si nos fijamos en la rotación de empleados,
la mitad de las organizaciones tienen muchos empleados descontentos.
Lo milagroso es que
no hay que gastar más dinero para que esto suceda.
No se trata de mesas de ping-pong, masajes y paseos de mascotas.
No se trata de los beneficios.
Se trata de cómo los tratan sus jefes
o compañeros de trabajo..
Me gustaría compartir algunas ideas que crean empleados felices.
Idea número uno:
en organizaciones donde los empleados están contentos,
se dan dos cosas:
confianza y respeto
Los jefes a menudo dicen:
"Confiamos en nuestros empleados.
Capacitamos a nuestros empleados".
Y cuando un empleado necesita una computadora,
y este es un ejemplo real,
15 personas tienen que aprobar la compra de esa computadora
Así que para el empleado, todas las palabras son correctas,
¿Pero 15 niveles de aprobación para una computadora de USD 1500?
En realidad, se ha gastado más dinero que la computadora en la aprobación.
Y el empleado siente que tal vez realmente no le tengan confianza.
Y ¿qué puede hacer una organización para tener un alto nivel de confianza?
La primera organización que me viene a la mente es Four Seasons.
Tienen propiedades magníficas en todo el mundo.
Y se les dice a sus empleados,
"Haga lo que crea que es correcto cuando atienda al cliente".
Otorgar confianza a los empleados para que así hagan lo que crean que es correcto
hace que los empleados se sientan bien.
Y por eso se les conoce por ofrecer algunos de los mejores servicios
en el mundo.
Idea número dos: la equidad.
Lo que erosiona la confianza en una organización.
más rápido que cualquier otra cosa
es cuando los empleados sienten que están siendo tratados injustamente.
Los empleados quieren ser tratados igual,
independientemente de su rango veteranía, edad,
experiencia o su categoría de trabajo,
en comparación con cualquier otra persona.
Al pensar en grandes organizaciones con actuaciones justas,
la primera organización que viene a la mente es Salesforce.
Ellos vieron que los hombres y mujeres que trabajan en el mismo trabajo
con el mismo nivel de competencia
recibían diferentes cantidades de dinero.
Así que de inmediato, calcularon la diferencia,
e invirtieron USD 3 millones para tratar de equilibrar las cosas.
La idea número tres es escuchar.
Para ser un oyente que se conecta con todo tipo de personas,
tenemos que desaprender algunas cosas.
A todos nos han hablado de la escucha activa y el contacto visual,
una mirada intensa
y una mirada compasiva.
Eso no es escuchar.
Repetir lo que dice la persona, eso no es escuchar.
Ser humilde
y siempre buscar la mejor idea posible.
eso es lo que es escuchar.
Y los empleados pueden sentir, si estás haciendo eso o no.
Quieren saber, cuando te hablan y comparten una idea,
si lo tomaste en cuenta al tomar una decisión.
Lo que todos aprecian y quieren cuando hablan
es saber que lo que dicen importa tanto
como para poder cambiar de opinión.
De lo contrario, ¿cuál es el objetivo de la conversación?
Todos sabemos las cosas que necesitamos cambiar,
Las cosas que tenemos que hacer de manera diferente.
La forma en que te comportas, la forma como tratas a los demás,
la forma como respondes, la forma como das apoyo,
define la experiencia laboral para todos los que te rodean.
Cambiar para ser una mejor persona.
El mundo está lleno de esos fracasos.
Pero cambiar porque hay algo en lo que crees,
algún propósito
por lo que estás dispuesto a arriesgar casi todo
por ser tan importante para ti.
Esa es la razón para cambiar.
Si no lo es, probablemente deberías encontrar otro puesto de trabajo.